(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
(gentle upbeat music)
♪ Standing in line, marking time ♪
♪ Waiting for the welfare dime ♪
♪ 'Cause they can't buy a job ♪
♪ Man in the silk suit hurries by ♪
♪ As he catches the poor old lady's eyes ♪
♪ Just for fun he says ♪
♪ Get a job ♪
(gentle upbeat music)
♪ That's just the way it is ♪
♪ Some things will never change ♪
♪ Ah, but don't you believe them, no ♪
(gentle upbeat music)
♪ Well, they passed a law in '64 ♪
♪ To give those who
ain't got a little more ♪
♪ But it only goes so far ♪
♪ 'Cause the law don't
change another's mind ♪
♪ When all it sees at the hiring time ♪
♪ Is the line on the color bar ♪
♪ That's just the way it is ♪
♪ Some things'll never gonna change ♪
♪ Ah, that's just the way it is ♪
♪ That's just the way it is,
it is, it is, it is, it is ♪
Give it up for Jason.
(gentle upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
Wow!
(gentle upbeat music)
(audience cheering and clapping)